la petite start up de paris saclay a
bien grandi depuis sa victoire à ap
innove et son passage aux crs de las
vegas anamnèse l'assistant virtuel des
professionnels de santé se développent
et cherchant visibilité dans le milieu
médical et dans de potentiels
investisseurs
sitôt qu'on a gagné ce le goulot
concours on n'a plus beaucoup plus
communiquer sur un amenait je pense que
ç'a permis de cristalliser les besoins
et les envies des investisseurs
d'investir chez nous on a pu réaliser
notre levée de fonds entre eux justement
novembre et janvier en 2018 charlotte
était stagiaire chez anamnèse grâce à la
victoire de la start up elle a pu se
faire embaucher par la suite en cdi une
évolution pour l'entreprise qui
accueille maintenant dix salariés et qui
s'attaque à de plus en plus de projets
le cf la maturité de la boîte aussi qui
avance au fur et à mesure les
différentes personnes qu on a pu
rencontrer tout ça fait que oui la boîte
elle a vraiment les projets ont changé
les l'émission aussi sont de plus en
plus intéressantes et ça nous ouvre des
portes
un avenir prometteur pour anne a mené ce
qui a pour vocation d'améliorer la santé
de la population et de s'implanter
prochainement à l'étranger premièrement
être capable de de réduire les
inégalités de vis-à-vis de la ce que
chacun peut avoir vis-à-vis de la santé
deuxièmement on a une grande capacité je
pense qu'on a un très bon catalyseur
pour développer la téléconsultation des
innovations dans le domaine de la santé
qui vont peut-être révolutionner la vie
des médecins infirmiers et patients
[Musique]